Salut, aujourd'hui on est mercredi !
Et le mercredi je donne des astuces
sur un peu tout. Cette semaine je voulais vous parler des verbes irréguliers en anglais.
Et puis .... hier, il s'est encore passé des trucs horribles ...en Belgique.
En réalité, je fais cette vidéo là mardi soir.
Donc je suis encore en plein dedans
et comme tout le monde, ça me touche...non ça me submerge en fait.
C'est assez terrifiant en fait, c'est extrêmement compliqué comme sentiment.
Alors que j'ai la chance de pas être directement touché par ça.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
J'ai donc beaucoup de mal à me dire "Et moi je vais faire ma petite vidéo !"
"Je vais faire ma petite vidéos du mercredi pour parler des verbes irréguliers" .
Donc je vais donner des astuces aujourd'hui comme tous les mercredis, mais ça va être des astuces pour profiter de l'instant présent.
Je vous donne 5 astuces pour profiter de l'instant présent,
réellement en fait, tout le temps, en profiter tout le temps,
et pas seulement quand quelque chose de grave s'est passé,
après quand on est dans l'envie de profiter,
mais en permanence.
ASTUCE N°1
c'est ce qu'on appelle la reconnexion :
c'est d'écouter l'autre avec une vraie écoute active.
Ça permet 2 choses :
ça permet de ne pas rester dans ce qui s'est passé précédemment,
donc dans le fil de nos pensées, ça évite de se projetter sur ce qu'on a à faire
le reste de la journée. Le fait de faire cette reconnexion ça va vous reconnecter aussi à l'instant présent,
à ce qui ce passe au moment où vous partagez avec une personne.
Donc voila astuce n°1 :
Prenez le temps de couper le fil de votre pensée, de ne pas penser à ce que vous voulez répondre à une personne quand elle aura fini de parler,
mais vraiment d'écouter ce qu'elle dit,
et de prendre une conscience globale de la conversation.
Ça nous rapproche les uns et les autres et ça vous remet dans l'instant.
L'astuce n°2,
c'est de se focaliser sur la réalisation, la focalisation sur la réalisation ou sur la mise en action.
alors ca c'est quelque chose que je connais très bien .je peux vous en parler.
Encore une fois le passé et le futur sont les plus présents dans nos vies .
c'est à dire que soit on se projette sur ce qu'on voudrait faire .
ce qu'on aimerait faire,ce qu'on aimerait avoir on serait plus heureux si il se passait ça ..
je serais plus heureux qu'en j'aurais fini ça
ou à contrario sur le passé ."ça" ça m'a miné  ou je suis encore sur un ancien échec ou sur une ancienne victoire.
mais en tout cas ça appartient au passé
la seule chose qui compte
c'est l'action du moment présent et donc la réalisation
quand on réalise..... on est centré que sur ça
que sur le moment .C'est à dire que là en ce moment avec les vidéos
avec les mental vlogs. Je vous le dis quand je mets une vidéo en ligne.
j'irai pas la revoir. J'irai pas la re-regarder. Je suis déjà en train de réaliser quelque chose .C'est à dire la prochaine vidéo.
je suis déjà en écriture
ça me permet d'être toujours dans l'instant.
j'ai engendré une mise en action.je suis dans une réalisation permanente.
donc ce qui importe en fait dans les projets
c'est pas la fin du projet
c'est pas sa mise en place
c'est de le faire .donc ayez toujours des projets.soyez vivant dans ce que vous aimez faire
mettez des actions en place
sur ce que vous aimez, dans ce qui vous passionne vous en permanence.
et vous serez dans la réalisation de ce que vous aimez
la finalité, elle est pas importante
ce qui est important c'est de le faire
la troisième astuce
pour profiter des instants présents
et la joie
c'est d'apprendre à dire NON
...et d'apprendre à dire OUI des fois il faut savoir dire non
ba heu non j'ai pas envie de m'obliger à faire ça. non, j'ai pas envie de t'aider à faire ça .
heu...non, ça ne m'interesse pas .C'EST PAS GRAVE.
c'est pas grave du tout en faite surtout si c'est au bénéfice de profiter de l'instant présent.
c'est juste de ne pas s'obliger à outrance. Voilà.
apprenez à dire NON  et donc de la même manière apprenez à dire OUI .
c'est trop facile de dire non je vais pas a cette soirée .ça va.. j'ai pas envie de bouger etc.
si vous n'avez pas de vraie raison de faire quelque chose ,obliger vous à dire oui
et ça va vous mettre dans des situations qui étais vraiment imprévue en fait .
et des situations encore une fois vivantes et vous allez plus profiter de certaines choses
donc il faut doser ses oui et ses non
si vous analysez vraiment votre comportement
il est similaire pour tout le monde je vous rassure.pour moi aussi
on a cette fâcheuse tendance à aller plus facilement vers la réponse opposé que celle qui faudrait vraiment adopter
et on le sait .c'est ça le pire
ASTUCE N°4
c'est une astuce qui est assez connue
qui est beaucoup repris dans les livres d'Eckhart Tolle
pour vivre l'instant présent,là,vraiment pleinement.il faut observer ses émotion
et observer le fil de sa pensée.là quand vous marchez dans la rue
quand vous êtes chez vous tous seul
vous pensez en permanence, on pense toujours par contre vous n'avez pas décider de votre pensée
c'est celle comme ca qui est envoyée par votre inconscient  etc
par les émotions
par votre état de fatigue
par plein de choses
si vous vous observez vous même
pensez et ressentir,c'est a dire vous prenez un moment pour dire
bon je suis comment là
je suis en colére mais pourquoi? est ce que je suis vraiment en colére contre ca ?
non..
non en fait c'est juste parce que j'étais fatigué
et donc en faite là j'ai une colére injuste vis à vis d'autre chose
le fait de s'observer
ca va stopper ce processus.
et quand on s'observe penser on peux décider de ce à quoi on pense
moi je le fais souvent dans le couloir du métro .je sais pas pourquoi
peut-être parce que je suis pris dans un flux
dans un mouvement et que tout ce fais naturellement et que j'ai des pensée un peu bizarres qui viennent
qui sont pas forcément décidées, comme si quelqu'un soufflait dans mon oreille mais c'est pas moi qui aie décider de penser a sa
et ben dans ces moment là,le fait de m'observer ca me ramène tout de suite à l'endroit où je suis
a observé les gens qui sont autour de moi
et ..et à même profiter de ce moment
on peut même profiter
d'un trajet en métro où on marche sur un changement de ligne
et l'ASTUCE N°5
c'est penser à dire MERCI
attention c'est pas une vidéo de gourous mais penser vraiment à dire merci
merci à rien
à personne en fait
tu vois merci pour tout
c'est pour s'habituer à avoir le sentiment de gratitude
parce que peut-être que la chose que vous vouliez absolument n'est pas arrivée aujoud'huis
mais il y a 1 000 chose sympas qui vous sont arrivées  que vous attendiez pas forcément
et même d'une maniére plus globale
de rester sur les choses plutôt positives
que les chose plus négatives
par exemple dans votre travail
il y a peut-être plein de choses qui vous agacent
mais malheureusement le mental s'attache vraiment à ca
c'est plus facile comme ca de s'attacher au chose comme ça agaçantes,c'est plus facile de s'en nourrir et derrière ca
derrière ces petites choses agaçantes
il y a 1000 et 1 chose qui sont géniales
peut-être que vous faites le métier que vous aimez
peut-être que vos collègues sont plutôt cools
peut-être que le métier que vous faites vous permet de passer plus de temps en famille
près de chez vous
peut-être que les études que vous faites vont vous permettre de faire un chouette métier
ou peut-être simplement que les études que vous faites vous permettent de voir des gens que vous aimez au quotidien
vous vous êtes fait des amis, ce genre de chose,il faut pas refuser qu'il y ait des choses positive autour de vous
c'est trop facile de dire ça va pas et rien ne va
donc il faut admettre toute ces choses positives
et dire merci pour ça
c'était mes 5 astuces là-dessus
j'avais envie de faire ça là-dessus aujourd'hui
j'espère que ça vous aura pas saouler
et j'espère vraiment que vous penserez à être heureux tout le temps
parce qu'on est pas toujours heureux par les évènements
on est heureux aussi parce qu'on décide de l'être
et .. euh..je crois qu'aujourd'hui plus qu'un autre jour
c'était important de s'en rappeller
je vais pas vous demander de vous abonner ,ce serait un petit peu indécent après tout ça
par contre en discutant aujourd'hui avec plein de monde sur internet.j'avais vraiment besoin de contact aujourd'huis
plutôt que d'être tout seul face a ma caméra
on m'a fait remarquer qu'on pouvait ouvrir la vidéos d'une manière plus participative
à plus de personnes sur YouTube y'a ce qu'on appelle les sous titre participatif,collaboratif
donc je vais ouvrir toute les vidéos en fait sur les sous titrage
j'ai pas encore regardé comment ça se faisait
si vous voulez m'aider à sous-titrer les vidéos, je pourrais jamais le faire moi-même, clairement, c'est si vous VOUS voulez les faire on le fait
mais je pourrais pas le faire moi, ça me ferait trop de choses en fait à faire. Ça permettrait que les personnes malentendantes ou non-entendantes du tout puissent suivre les vidéos donc
on a déjà 82 vidéos de retard dans ce cas
et puis ça permettrait aussi après que les  personnes ne parlant pas le Français puissent traduire rapidement les sous-titres avec Google translat ou quelque chose comme ça
donc si ça vous tente vous me le dites en fait dans les commentaires si vous voulez faire partie de ça
même pour faire une demie-vidéo un petit bout de vidéo
je me dis que là on doit être à peu près à 2 080 abonnés
au moment où je fais cette vidéos
donc on peux se repartir les tâches si ça vous tente
vous m'en parlez dans les commentaires ou sur Facebook ou sur twitter ou sur snap ..on peut s'en causer .
Voila j'espère que vous avez le moral en cette fin de journée
j'ai une GROSSE GROSSE PENSEE POUR TOUTE LA BELGIQUE
et puis et puis  pour tous ceux qui connaissent du monde là-bas
je crois juste que ça nous fait bugger , ça nous met de grosses gifles, autour, même quand on est loin de l'évènement
Je vous donne rendez vous à 17h sur la chaine. Je vous promet d'être un petit peu enjoy. Là c'était plus compliqué d'être speed ce soir mais je vais m'en remettre à l'astuce 2 et me focaliser sur la réalisation.
à très bientôt prenez soin de vous ciao
...